[Music]
deep beneath the quaint village of
cecilton evil was brewing
an infection
one capable of turning its host into a
feared mind flare a being of immense
psychic power
four heroes took to that task
warned what a huff elf bard
nest an elven druid corvus conrad a
witch hunter and were bob a goliath
barbarian
in the streets of their hometown they
fought they slaughtered the infected who
had turned into these aberrations but of
all the infected one did not turn into a
beast
a young orphan named twimothy
with hope that there might be a cure
they ventured further but the young
orphan was abducted by the mind flares
lurking beneath the ruins of the
neighboring town they found their hive
and with might and magic they cleansed
it extinguishing the threats of the
overworld and saving the young orphan
but just as they felt their problems
were now behind them to their surprise a
driver greeted them with a grave message
the destruction they witnessed above
ground was only the beginning
now our heroes journey deeper
underground
but one still carries the infection with
him and could turn into a mind player
at any moment
everyone comes out down at this cave a
mind flare is straight in front of you
roll initiative oh god
are you savage what
oh no and we're down i'm down on spells
and i don't have my level knives welcome
to season two of son of a dungeon hello
everyone warren watt here again my
character's name is he's a wood elf
druid i'm back playing corvus conrad
corvis conrad is a human witch hunter my
name is wabob i'm a goliath barbarian
you drop into what used to be a mine but
has now been stripped and abandoned it
is dim but between the mine flares you
see two thrall holding torches and the
mind flare was standing there
as if expecting something else to come
down
inspecting something else and so the
mind player steps back and readies an
attack oh man immediately the mind
player psychic blasts it got a 20 on
initiative all right everyone rolls a
dc-15 intelligence saving throw
okay okay i got a 16. 16. yeah you're
good
15 exactly what's good you're good
oh my god
what are you doing what are you getting
shots nine nine psychic blast comes out
nest and
both take 19 points of damage and are
stunned for a minute now all right
immediately after that corvus can go i'm
at 18 hd guys i don't even know what i
can do sam has the timer now oh yeah oh
yeah
i'm to use my blood ripe as a bonus
action cut myself and smear blood onto
my crossbow basically imbue it with fire
damage i get a plus one to attack with
it and then i also do an extra d8 damage
of fire damage every time i attack with
it
i'm at
i'm at nine hp right now i'm gonna do
two shots on him
14
and then a 16. hit 14 damage oh that's a
lot of damage for bolt i'm gonna back up
uh behind the dryer
just so i understand it's the
adventuring party plus twimothy was a
driver yes that's it first of all
i'm not a fighter everyone knows this
i hate these mind player things to begin
with
and i look at my two best boys
incapacitated
so i
get all my might together and i
call myself can i cast lehman's tiny hot
courtesy of lehman
sweet well boom the bubble forms
everyone seems to be protected it's
you're right in the middle it's perfect
everyone's surrounded by the hut you see
the mind player change his stance when
you cast that spell you're both still
stunned so then the driver turns to
warren it says what it should what is
this force field chip can i go out and
attack still
this force field is safe as long as
you're inside of it magic cannot be cast
through it but you can leave it and come
back in as long as i don't leave it i'm
too scared to fight these things what do
you mean you're too scared to do would
you like a font of inspiration okay okay
all right
[Music]
drivers you can do it okay come on
all right so the driver creeps out from
the hut and runs up to one of the thrall
and rolls into attack on i give you a
1v8
to add to whatever you're doing
six he runs up to the thrall and and
just angrily tense and gains the courage
a multi-attack scores a triple hit on
him yes oh boy he deals 12 damage and
poison damage to the throne just starts
cutting him with the sharp pincers and
eviscerates him and he just topples over
and
all the body parts just get shredded
into the floating water that's at your
feet i yell from the hut i knew you
could do it buddy it's twimothy's turn
twimothy is scared and he backs up next
to core this year oh no i forgot we had
a twin with you with us yeah he's like a
little he's just like
[Music]
as long as you're in here the spells
can't cast through it'll be okay we got
eight hours we've got a lot of time to
figure this out and
roll runs up to the driver to try and
attack it the thrall swings at the
driver this is the mind player walks up
to the edge of the tiny hut and starts
staring everyone down and like realizing
it can't
pass through this and it turns to the
driver and casts the spell the triter's
out of the bubble he cast it
successfully and he turns back oh god
now he's got the driver the driver can
come in here if it's mind control oh
no
oh no i did tell the driver
uh i'm very much bloodied i don't have
any heals um i'm out of spell slots i
could use a juice box
um basically if you don't tell me what
you do you spent your time talking all
right i'm just going to shift over here
in front of twimothy and i am going to
light this boy up all right
[Music]
16 does that hit
29 damage about half of that is fire
damage
6666
oh my gosh all right so he's bloody i am
going to uh viciously mock him of course
and uh and then i am going to cast uh
i can't do both wait one's a cantrip
one's a spell one's they're both actions
damn it and here goes the timer all
right hold on that's fine you can roll
that timer that's fine i got i got
plenty of times now yeah i get like 20
seconds
okay
i'm going to take those 20 i'm gonna
take all 20.
the battle is raging
warren steps back thinks ponders i can't
step out okay i'm gonna cast vicious
mockery on him can i roll against it
it must succeed on a wisdom-saving throw
oh then it's a 17. all right so you lost
you took six six oh it's like an
embarrassing memory
[Laughter]
you're stunned you're stunned and you're
stunned so roll against the stun again
i shouldn't have tweeted that late at
night
you're not stunned okay next turn you
get to move you found this turn
unstunning oh
it really sucks it really sucks it's the
driver's turn now the driver just starts
splashing at this other throw and he
gets the throw bloodied with seven
points of damage from one strike oh the
thrall's all bleeding and bloody it's
the mind players turn
the mind player looks at you guys
the mind flare steps back one step
cast a spell cast a spell
typical um wait we can do can anyone
detect you just realize he did a spell
called plane shift oh wow
there's one thrall left
oh boy okay
i see the mineflower
oh thank god i walk up and put the
crossbow up to this dude's head you walk
up to the back of his head the first
ball goes in and falls dead and you keep
shooting and with the rest of the arrows
until
he's not moving
okay okay
all right and that's the end of combat
oh man
what happened
that was intense what happened hey
what's going on buddy i've never seen
mind player
do that before didn't you just come from
this way yes so how was it how did you
miss
the mind player and the it's 500 feet it
took me over it took me a half hour to
climb at least we're safer now i should
i need to bring you to the camp who sent
you who sent
would you like to know everything tell
us on the way okay just i made this i
forgot to show this to you i made a
whole map showing where cecilton and
when hingham shire was father
mcallister's orphanage there and you'll
actually notice that in that first
season you can see that there are mines
you'll notice on there that these mines
people work there in fact i mean there's
even a place called camp crushers ah you
know because once again
it's the sports team
sports teams are frequently named after
famous trades parts of the economy
and things like that so obviously the
pressure's you know stone crushers
mining et cetera camp crusher camp
crushers this is something that
specifically corvus found in the depths
of the mind flare layer there's one
moment when after you find trimothy you
found this on a bookshelf which is a
rudimentary map of the mines whoa so it
goes way
deep what's that bottom word
measures gate that's miles deep curic
cam kurick curl curl
yeah so so what do they mine down there
because we would know right but
obviously there's elements in here that
are like there's just there's coal down
here there's iron ore there's other
things like that and then what you'll
notice is that there's two mines there's
a there's a smaller one and a larger one
you'll see like the elevator shafts
there basically the smaller one is the
original mine that was you know that's
where the
crushers came from etc that was like the
very first one
there's like some red writing here
there's some secret stuff around it
looks like there's some secret stuff is
this
mesmer's gate mezzanine's gate so
basically in digging that even deeper
mine they found that there were drow
communities even deeper there's
basically an agreement which is we
are going to not interact with each
other we're not going to do trade if you
imagine throughout history here when you
run into drought if you're underground
you're on their turf you know there have
been rumors that in the past people had
seen drow above land to like take people
and enslave them and bring them back and
use them for slaves underground in their
minds it's russia down there yeah okay
so there's no action
but what you've heard is basically
there's just there's a
big ass gate that basically is blocked
off and they never opened it is this
camp crusher right here this looks like
cam crushers and down here there's
another pool and it's coming from
mesner's gate one more thing before we
get into it before departing corvus you
accepted the clerics here for the
tadpole he casts greater restoration on
you however that left nest to be the one
hero still infected wait nico's still
infected oh yeah tumethi still infected
too yes i think so yeah so nico nico
nico yeah
let's figure this out basically we had a
bunch of npcs last time get infected and
i had a certain amount of time that took
for them to basically fall you know to
the infection this could be pretty
simple nico i got a i got a dice here
it's a one
all right
you're gonna roll a constitution check
against a one every time you roll i flip
this timer and when it runs out the
number goes up by one
and it keeps doing that until you either
figure out a solution
or die
okay okay uh roll against the one don't
get a one
okay i got 12. cool you're good so next
time it's going to be a two okay all
right hey i'm gonna make us propose a
solution right now you guys uh
shoot you cannot get to the camp without
the driver when you get to the campus
how far is the camp the camp is right
around the corner here okay we we took
it over as we left the underdark strider
is there anybody in this camp that can
help me i have a worm in my head
i have a tablet in my head
yes the cleric uh we have a cleric
greater restoration let's go let's go
right now okay let's go right now
that's why we're here that's why we're
here
okay
what
what don't say
anything
what about it oh for sure first okay i'm
going to pretend
something else is wrong with me i'll
figure out what it is on the way there
yes let me do a quick perception check
on this full uh uh like how i'm running
out of time all right never mind let's
go
go go follow me follow me okay we'll
follow so
he goes and pushes open the store
okay so the driver walks up very
carefully he makes a little clicking
noise
and
from further ahead
we hear a response
and he walks up to the stairs and he
says i'm i'm back i'm back i've found
someone i found someone that could help
from within the the gates you can you
hear a voice in like
who who is it
who did you find i i found heroes from
above that that they killed
i know
many mind flares
they can fight them
show them
bring them forward he says come on up
here
you see through the gates behind two
arrow slits see two dark drow faces over
here the woman speaks up says
are these them they don't look like
heroes we were ambushed when we came
down here they they they frightened him
or something because he he seemed to
disappear so she says well well then
okay are they are they clean wait i'll
look over at you real quick and i'm like
what are we gonna say you have i have uh
do they have proof like vaccinations
anything lady proof prove it how how do
we prove it what do you mean prove it
what do you mean clean prove that you're
not infected i i show her how like
damaged i am like we need help we need
healing the mind flare head
how can i be infected if i have the head
wow
they have killed them okay we can kill
more of them we need healing though we
need to be restored before we let anyone
in we have to test you
lady oh primer nico uh it's a two rolled
against a two
twenty
we want the same thing that you want we
want to find and destroy all the mind
flares but we need to get inside because
we don't know what's out there and we
were just attacked we fled our city
because it has been overrun we've heard
that hundreds we've talked from two
other cities that we've been through
already
and the only reason that anyone is still
standing is because of us
open the gate open the gate thank you
good talking good test nice he opens the
gate here
and he says step forward
another drow he comes up to the edge and
he says all right come in quickly come
on let's go let's go like we do not lift
these gates open
hey hey dryder what's your name my name
is crick prick crick yes okay craig nice
to meet you and then as the driver walks
up the drought closes the doors
you keep out there okay you're gonna
keep out there under the furnaces yes
this drought peeks up look we don't let
him in here he's not worth it okay he's
not he's not one of us you want to
understand is that because of his legs
yes he's failed okay
so okay do not worry about him all right
come here inside you walk into what is
obviously camp crushers you can tell us
camp crushers because inside you see
like a cecilton crusher's banner inside
like one of the houses as you walk past
it's quiet like stuff is tipped over
things are kind of like ripped up only a
few people in here in fact as you walk
in you see there's a lot of other drow
trying to keep this place
guarded so you walk up the priestesses
greetings
my name is
laylee where are we laila
excuse me
lele
we bring you in here
in a mat with with a certain level of
trust and you laugh at my name
priestess lele we sincerely apologize
that it's because he has a stick called
the chilele anyways it's a it's an
inside joke
it's an inside
apologies your majesty yes look you have
to understand this is not the first
place we've tried to hide as we've made
our way up from the underdark we've seen
hundreds of debt and and and this is the
only camp we found that offers us any
form of protection we can't go higher
came up through messner's gate yes and
the whole town has been completely
overrun oh man i have such a bad
headache oh my headache is real bad but
i'm still okay do you our friend is
really sick from all the battle i am
also very wounded we're all happy
especially if you happen to
have a greater restoration spell you can
cast on him are you the cleric are you i
am a cleric what what what are you who
are you looking for i am in desperate
need of a greater restoration spell then
that is quite sad
the only person who could cast the
greater restoration spell fell down that
pit
what pit which the pit we just came down
this the shaft
fell down the pit yes
three
maybe four hours ago a group of thrall
tried to break through the city and she
had all her spells and she was helping
us
subdue them but it seemed like as she
retreated
she was out of spell slots when she cast
spider climb and tripped and fell down
the pin she died are you sure
do you know how she fell down did you
find her body i'm not go i can't climb
down there i can't cast spider climb and
this the damn shaft is broken how deep
does it go probably an another several
hundred feet oh god oh okay yeah my
50-foot rope won't be long
priestess lele do you have any
lesser restoration you could help our
friend with in the meantime he has
lesser restoration yes
but what what is why why do you need
that
uh i've been cursed
what i've been cursed it's not
contagious yeah it's like a casual curse
how long ago how long ago has that
happened uh it happened about
30 minutes ago 30 minutes ago fighting
the mind flare what
but you could you could you could black
out and you could turn into one at any
moment we don't know how long it takes
no no no no no no no no no no no it's
not an infection it's a curse
we need to
get rid of it we need to get rid of him
that's not how this game works we won't
survive unless we're together so we need
to heal him so that how do we heal him
we need somebody who can castrate a
restoration isn't there another way
can we cut it out or something do you
know any other way of potentially
reversing this or anything close to
greater risk all i know is that when an
infected person dies the tadpole exits
the body sensing the host is no longer
living
that's the first step
unless
there is a spell i can pass called
reviveify
it's
basically if we kill you
we can cast revivify and bring him back
to life after the tadpole has exited
oh man sounds like a rock you have to
actually kill him yes it brings a corpse
back to life
as long as the corpse has been dead for
under one minute is this is there a
chance that you will fail your spell i
have adv i have hunter's bane so i
basically bring up anything i might know
about it and like how legit this sounds
14 14 that's fine that's plenty revive
fight it's well she's telling the truth
it's necromancy and you can look at
these people they worship death and loaf
and spider [ __ ] you know and so she's
gonna she's gonna use necromancy so that
she's proposing that so do i know if he
does get brought back to life will he be
the same is he going to be like undead
is he uh reviveify touches a living
creature that's died within the last
minute preacher returns to life with one
hit point returns to life returns to
life i'd like to insight to see if she
is authentically wanting to help me
17. that this is the one solution she's
grasping for other than her previously
proposed solution of just straight up
killing you
and leaving it at that i know this does
not sound ideal but i do know of the
spell she speaks and it will work okay
you will survive but you will be very
weak what we could do is allow the spell
to happen
rest and then go down because at any
point if you black out
in the middle of something while we need
you and then you that's really rough i
think i think we got to do this
so you're saying you want to gamble on
your life she says you're already
gambling with all of our lives by even
being
that's true this is the one exception
we've never let a single infected in we
need to save space to do this the
lodging is over in the corner let's go
and let's do this now okay
this way
dude it's got a sword shield on the wall
all right i'm gonna lie down
all right uh so nico you get to the bed
and you lie down you have to roll
against the four
all right i'm good 17. all right
i don't like that i don't like this game
i look over at you i go so the way this
works i will let you decide
but we have to
bring your hp to zero yeah and then then
she can cast the spell and revive you we
can either
[Laughter]
other than that it's like poison but
that'll still be in your system so the
best way to go about it is for will bob
to smother you
with a pillow or something and then
right when you die they cast the spell
okay
wait i can't believe is it okay that
quickly hold on i need to think about
this for a second twimothy walks up to
corbin corvis what's happening i go
twimothy
we're just
we're just going to play a game real
quick with next
[Music]
i go i go
let's keep that between you and me okay
okay for now just we're gonna keep that
between us okay okay all right here's
another idea what if you just like slit
your wrists and let yourself bleed out
yeah layla speaks up like perhaps uh
instead of suffocation maybe that's like
a a magical spell
wait you're a bard can't you
psychically damage him up there and talk
[ __ ] to him until he dies
[Laughter]
no it won't be it won't be physical
damage which is what we need to avoid
here and i'm picking the lesser of two
evils no no but he'll always remember
those things guys
i start taking out my camp supplies and
i sit down like the floor next to the
bed and they start brewing a cup of
nutmeg tea which is going to put me into
a daze so that i don't have to think
about this too much what is happening
corvus i want you to do this mothering
because i don't trust bob's strength
okay i imagine he's gonna break my nose
in the process you have the dexterity of
a surgeon
i'd have warren do it but he's more for
tickling the strings than the keys as
opposed to like tickling my
throat
okay so basically yeah you hear like a
little
ding ding ding
you just hear a bell ringing and layla
one second where are you going
open the door and one of the drought
says
there's another throw horde coming
and it looks like five or six of them
let's do this now you hear some ballista
balls start firing outside layla says we
must do this uh quickly as there's a
an urgent matter i need to attend to
shortly all right
sipping my tea oh man i'm super dazed
all right your super days close my eyes
all right
you only have to kill me 25 hp okay i'm
gonna you have 25 hp yeah
shake out
hold on how long does it take to
suffocate someone in d d it'll take you
one plus your constitution modifier
that's how many minutes it'll take for
you to begin
start suffocating two minutes all right
gentlemen listen
lauren i want to write a song about this
moment about my last breath that's a
great title for your song nest's last
breath oh man this just got way better i
just exhaled
play a song i need to sing there i need
you to calm me down with this play a
song i grab the pillow
just to make it extra effected i'm going
to take out a water flask and i'm just
going to um pour water and wet the
pillow the waterboard
i apply an even amount of pressure
around his mouth and nose and i keep it
and i hold it down i go with you look
away it's happening you're currently
suffocating him first minute passes and
then
roll a strength check against nico i
need to get out
27. you have him grappled he is not
moving at all you're good you're good
he's suffocating i feel him tweaking i'm
like it's it's gonna happen soon she
starts preparing magical whispers to
start forming between her hands i summon
loathe's blessing
to cast the spell
bring him back to life both he's not
dead yet he's not dead yet okay almost
dead hold on i feel the last bit
slipping out
and
he stops twitching hold on i can't cast
it yet we have to wait for the tadpole
to come out oh look all right i grabbed
the torch and i'm waiting i
i have my dagger out i'm waiting for the
tadpole we're watching this is like just
still dead
nothing's happening yet it's not coming
out it's it's trying to use its
dexterity to escape the body oh no
oh my god i'm running rolling ones and
twos and threes tan there we go
oh there it is there it is there it is
you got it okay okay
she starts casting her well it's
blessing
she cast it and life sucks back into
your body and getting one hit point
oh my headache's gone but i feel like
[ __ ]
all right hey what did you see on the
other side i
saw i don't say anything because i know
what he saw
you become aware that something is
linked to your mind
another mind
much larger mind an enormous mind of
incredible intelligence it feels
like it can see everything you see and
if you roll in a charisma check right
now
you can shake that feeling
six feeling doesn't shake it's weird it
feels like someone's watching it now
anyways it worked
it's the first time i've ever done that
oh this means
anytime we find someone who's infected
we have a way to cure them without using
greater restoration when's the next time
you can use that spell i think i can use
it one more time today that's it also
twimothy's totally fine twimothy is
totally okay yes i'm i'm totally fine
i'm totally fine uh one moment everyone
one moment uh let me see if everything's
okay out here
she just leaves you hear the bell still
ringing and you hear some of the
crossbow bolts
getting fired i lean over to you and i
go
i go
you are another one who's been touched
by death yeah
like me it's pretty crazy we're like
soul brothers it was pretty nuts right
it was pretty sick yeah nuts
talk about it later but first we gotta
get out of this together yeah yeah i go
uh all right i go twimothy
let's forget everything you solved we're
not gonna let this happen to you we're
gonna figure out what's going on the
bell stops ringing lately checks back is
everything okay still
yeah i'm getting my energy back it
appears this worked that means there's a
path forward in case we find other
infected would you be willing to come
with us and help us along the way
absolutely i will how's the uh thrall
problem going well uh
there's a few that
i guess upon that moment this sensed
that
maybe they needed to come here for some
reason obviously he's infected in these
thrall they're being dominated and so
of course there's a link here did you
successfully ward off the thrall
invasion yes but they keep coming you
see there's a there's many of them in
the mine over it appears they're
harvesting crystals for some reason i
don't know what they want with it how
many
uh fighters or warriors do you have here
defending this place we have what you
see there's myself and four others
that's it
yes
let's
because i definitely i desperately need
a long rest uh so let's do
long rest and then maybe switch shifts
is a good idea just out why don't you go
and and bob and i will stay up and then
we'll go swimming there you seem you're
probably tired yes absolutely okay you
rest here okay hey does this bed belong
to anybody did this buzz no not anymore
i closed my eyes
all right and i tried to fall asleep all
right
i just did it you initiated a long
take the first shift yep
and everyone else rests
all right bob look let's see
what a day kill
like
three no four mine flares two let's just
say end of day recap the party kills
four mine players four and a half four
and a half
ish yeah uh and uh yeah it's uh and then
that that whole thing happened nest died
came back to life
great so they began resting warn
well bob step out
into the courtyard
i could really use some music i'll play
you a tune i just i need some i need
something to get me going to get across
this courtyard three sheets to the wind
three sheets to the wind
i've been around the world and back
again
three sheets to the wind is where i
begin
until my time comes to an end
and we'll all go sailing on
okay well bob we need to talk with
prince peace tesla a little bit figure
out a little bit more about what's going
on where is she she's right here i'm
right next to you sorry
i'm sorry i wasn't looking down enough
yes hi
how are your defenses here currently our
defense is held it appears that the
thrall only come here just to remind us
of their presence there hasn't been a
large attack that makes us want to flee
what we need to do is go deeper into the
underdark and
save
save our city and save our house
and
hopefully we can kill the rest of the
mind flayers i agree with you we need to
go deeper that's the only way this is
going to get solved if we stay here
we're just going to end up
getting overrun at some point do you
know
of any quick
ways to
and past mesner's gate fastest ways
to somehow get this shaft operate
getting the get the lift to be able to
operate properly and i guess we would be
able to board it and go straight down if
we go through
camp choral back to the main gate that's
the fastest way but first things first
we got an engineer solution to your gait
problem yes there's it seems there's a
few key pieces that are missing it seems
like some stuff got scattered throughout
the mines here there's a particular like
it's a lever-like key that's supposed to
keep everything running smoothly and
without this
there's
it seems like there's no way to
get it to
operate safely uh bob maybe we should
look around for this thing first have
you guys looked i assume you've looked
oh yes absolutely we've taken everything
all the gold all the tools everything
all the gold yes absolutely everything
we found we put in the okay let's go in
there and see okay maybe it's in there
whoa look at that storehouse you guys
going here in the storehouse she says
this is all we found all right so the
base is up on the shelf they contain uh
there's food there's food supplies up
there there's uh stuff for brewing
ingredients for for beer for uh just
yeah provisions i go i say bob
maybe it is a good thing if we all sleep
i'm pretty tired we have the mining
supplies our solution's probably in here
i'm going to take a bedroll and just lay
it out on the floor
in front of this fireplace and just
sleep do you have any trees down here
trees no of course not can i have the
table sure
i take the table with me as you pick up
the table a bunch of papers fall off and
jay goes over to inspect it and he sees
a printed flyer of sorts that says in
camp cural they are excited to have the
grand opening of a lehman's express
very soon express and it's dated to
well it was supposed to happen about
five days ago i fold this up in my
pocket what does it say when we all wake
up
we've got big news to talk about with
the others oh boy
and i put it in my phone i go right into
the middle of the courtyard plop down
the the table and i lay underneath it a
long way so it's it only covers like
half my body sounds good and are you
going to rest in the yeah i'm going to
sleep right there i might need some of
this stuff later all right well we'll we
will wake you if there's any trouble
thank you priestess
everyone wants to sleep so long long
rests now that you've had a time to for
a long rest it's been four to eight
hours probably just eight even though
nico's an elf only needs four but eight
hours have passed and you awaken now
able to use all your ninth level
abilities and spells
yes as if you weren't overpowered
already it's it's gonna get crazy
however what happens when you wake up
well you wake up you feel great you feel
rested it's been a long time
nest wakes up that feeling of someone
watching it still persists corpus when
you wake up you suddenly have that
feeling as well too well bob you wake up
feeling that same sensation as well oh
wow oh my god what what's in my head if
he tells you he's feeling the same thing
by the way chippy perks up scissors
you're feeling the same way too well
that's happening i roll up my bed roll i
put it on my with my stuff and i make my
way back out across the courtyard to the
house plenty awakens
and he gasps
and immediately rushes over to you
chorus and says
i had a dream i think or something but
tell me of the stream
when i went to sleep
something happened it still feels like
it but i saw something i saw more mind
flayers
like i heard them again and i heard
something even bigger larger than any
mind flare i've spoken with before
something that feels hundreds of times
bigger it is enormous and it's got an
enormous amount of strength and energy
deep below i saw everything i saw all of
the mind flares in one single instant i
saw
a hive
i heard a message they've been here
looking and searching for something for
a number of years waiting for a special
time and place where they would find a
wizard by the name of lehman
and that moment apparently
happened and they found him they found
dull lehman
sir
they're looking for him because they
think he has access to a spell powerful
enough to secure them on this plane for
eons wait so you you saw that they have
him or they're looking for it it was a
sensation
that they have
located him they haven't gone to him yet
okay i don't know
who he is or where he is
they they want something a spell or
something that he's capable of casting
timothy
did you say
sir lehmann that was the word the name i
heard i've never heard that name before
the great wizard i guess you've said it
once in a while
they're going to be opening a lehman's
express
in curacao camp cure okay so we're not
far from camp cural we
need to take the shaft down to get the
cam coral um but she said the shaft was
broken there is a missing crank shaft or
something that we need to find it's a
bit of a it's a it's a machined key how
is everyone else feeling i feel fine
nice as long as he keeps the ring on
he should be okay does anybody else have
a ring of well i have one on what what
do you what do you mean the ring what
are you guys we gave him the ring
feeling weird i am feeling weird what do
you what's wrong i uh sensed the same
thing when i passed into the afterlife
for like 30 seconds and now
i will fail the same thing when i woke
up this morning i feel this presence as
well
so whatever we're dealing with that
could just be because you guys all had
tadpoles in your brain i felt it too
what i didn't have a tadpole in my brain
but i had a weird dream if you were to
take your ring off which i'm not saying
do you would probably feel the same
thing but i'm saying keep it keep the
ring on uh i'm gonna say that you take
the ring off and then you give it to me
why can you give me something in
exchange for this i could be the wanda
magic missile uh i don't know what's
gonna happen if i take this off i might
have a headache
take it off you feel fine
i don't know what you guys are talking
about
missile
time is ticking we need to decide what
we want to do with twimothy how old are
you timothy how old am i well i'm 13.
have you ever seen a dead body
yes how many have you seen
only the ones that you've made well
timothy
there comes a time in every child's life
when they need to grow up and become a
man and uh i think you should join our
band of very compatriots and you should
fight alongside of us i'm just worried
that's gonna be a little traumatic for
you but if you think you can handle it
then let's handle it together only if
you feel like you can handle it though
maybe we should you can handle it i
don't want to put him in harm's way
because if he gets harmed physically he
might mentally lose it yeah what i want
to do is figure out
why
i feel the way i feel now when i was an
orphan i felt powerless
you know the feeling and ever since
i got this
whatever this was in my mind like i
i feel different now i feel like i have
like a purpose i can be something now
like i'm not just some kid that doesn't
matter because he doesn't have a family
great example right there
example you know and i want
once i realized that there was more in
me than
just being nothing i want to
explore that okay
well
i got you all right let's uh
before we do that if you're going to
join our adventuring party
we may want to discuss getting the
tadpole out of your brain do we have to
this is exactly what what do you mean
why are you questioning this this is
clear if you can handle it
here he'll he'll handle for are you nuts
first of all are you nuts have you had a
tadpole in your brain if this tadpole is
what is giving he's making me feel the
way i do then no i don't want to take it
out
i don't want to go back to the way i
used to be i'll take responsibility for
what happens to twin few okay okay okay
all right and i also look over you guys
i'm like
antagonized
[Laughter]
all right back in the courtyard reese's
lele hello we found a bunch of mining
supplies in this storage house yes yes
we may be able to fix the shaft
incredible with those has anything else
happened in the meantime oh we killed
three more thrall no big deal there's a
small there's kind of a pile building up
right now but that should stop them for
a while until they clear it because what
we'd like to do is fix this shaft and
then get out of here we should bring
everyone that sounds good bring your
whole party we have not left the
compound the driver is stays outside and
keeps watch for us well we got to pick
one way to go let's
this one right here has a question mark
on it
i suggest we check that christmas okay
let's do it yeah whatever would be on
the southeast side of where we are
so there's no sun so i'm just like you
look over here
here so let's go straight into another
kill hole here and uh there's a gate
protected there and as you look through
that
pile of bodies
dead people those are thralls they're
all that occasionally bugged them i walk
up to the other drow guards and i just
ask them for their names oh yeah my name
is sizzix zyzix yes and how about your
friend here he's correct sizzix and
corks i'm warren watt i'm going to take
a peek through those bars there just
pass the perception on it 19. and as you
look through the bars further in what
you also see is you can kind of just
make out the forms of other people
working away in here slapping them rocks
i think i'm just going to start killing
you sense that there is a creature
right
here and it's large
you're like something big is over there
but with a 19 perception you can't make
out other than you are aware that
there's something big up there you know
these aerostats are just about the size
of chipmunk
let me ask plenty as chippy i'm also
kind of up there with them
chippy doesn't want to go
anywhere other than my shoulder
really
yeah really really yeah really
no way i'd like to persuade chippy if
you'd be open to it
he's not open to it at all are you open
to it i'm open to it i'm going to
persuade chippy uh i mean i can do the
role i have oh i have all the chicky
stuff up here you world of what 24.
uh it it succeeds i go well bob could
you tell him to
go investigate and see what he finds and
i've never asked anything of you before
oh no
do it for me yeah okay fine
and then he uh takes off takes off he's
a member of the party
he has like a plus
four for stealth 11. so i'm literally
just chilling with you guys so you're
you're piloting a drone basically yeah
dude i'm just like freaking beast fpv
crown drone that's wait how have we not
done this before you can see everything
he sees yeah oh that's sweet no i can
see anything any animal sees as long as
i touch them first okay wow and i have
to concentrate right now i just broke my
concentration where did chippy go hold
up okay there you go
so chippy goes through
it goes out here crawls through the
little bodies a bit of a pile of blood
and it's like freaking you know whatever
whatever movie so he goes up here to get
a vantage point and what he sees is two
baby mine flares they together seem to
be casting uh some sort of levitation
telekinesis spell lowering a big box of
these uh glowing crystals down into the
shaft
and chippy goes okay not gonna go closer
than that and looks around what he sees
is what the big creature was which is
this there's this giant orbiting
floating thing with each of its
tentacles that are moving in in sync
there every once in a while they seem to
be just kind of like
reinforcing magical energy on the miners
as the and kind of directing them and
telling them what to do and it's just
sitting there floating there maintaining
control of all the thrall in this area
chippy just circles one more time and
sees up here what looks to be like a
weird contraption looking thing that he
doesn't know what it's for
but it's like a little gear box that's
what we need and that's when the red
mind witness
creature
suddenly just slowly turns his big eye
to it and notices it running and just
watches it leave
and it casts one spell on it really
quickly
he's probably like those aren't supposed
to be down here
he sees a run by and he's like
nothing happens nothing happens here
everything's all good
chippy is
done with this he's coming back eyeball
it sees me so it's time to leave hops
back onto your shoulders
see that wasn't so bad
uh so he says that he saw
a bunch of little baby mine flares
and they seemed to be kind of just
levitating this box with some crystals
in it
and also there's this giant monster in
there that was it what did the monster
look like see any contraption that we
might use oh yeah uh he said he was
standing on a contraption no idea what
it was
and that the monster was way bigger than
him if this giant monster is looking and
psychically controlling people he'll
probably be able to protect you guys
right away yeah so
he didn't detect me
there's no way you're gonna be stealth
in there with full plate mail what if we
just run in swords blazing blazin
blazing
i love that phrase
all i know is that from what you've told
me this whatever this monster creature
is that is looking at all these people
it is probably what is controlling the
thrall so instead of being bogged down
by all the ads
we can
potentially take out what's controlling
them it'd be the righteous thing to do
also rather than murdering all these
people that are technically innocent
yeah they're goo boys right they look
like they're miners these are seasonal
crushers these are people who are
normally down here doing it except they
have been
taken over they're probably going to
attack us
when that happens so we'll you know try
to kill as few of them as possible when
that does occur or we could try
not to kill them perhaps there's another
way around let's go the other way going
the other way makes sense but guys i
just i gotta think for a second let me
roll a knowledge object to see if i can
identify that creature
all right so uh well from his
description you can tell that it's some
form of bolder it doesn't seem to be
acting
like a beholder would that's what you
know he's like he kind of described a
beholder but you know beholders are kind
of like big boss things that aren't like
just kind of like not beholden to
anybody yeah they aren't beholden to
anyone and so to see it kind of like in
this sub-servant role means there's it's
not
this isn't going to be your average one
a holder can fly
like it's not it doesn't walk so it can
easily just escape our grass we're
trying to get close to it and
based on my perception of this cave the
ceilings are about say it's about 30
feet so that's some that's i think up 30
feet in the air we're all going to be
able to hit with a ranged attacks i can
actually fly he can literally fly i can
i mean
jumping is like flying what do you mean
you can fly i can i can jump i meant to
say i could jump i can make people fly
describe the limitations of this because
this could be really useful right now so
you can just like
fly us yes what you could do is
depending on the range we can sneak up
close
we go in this
and then you float with bob in so he
doesn't have to worry about his stealth
i just give him the ability it's an
insane spell that's insane what you
could do
is give it to will bob yeah he could
rage out
we'll cast invis
yeah float close
yeah and if you can invis bob he can do
damage bob needs to get close before
this guy can fly away and like put
people between him and him i can't make
him invisible and make him fly i can do
one or the other the lightly speaks up
so if there's a
a beholder in there or something you
said seems to be the problem yeah
what if poison did we poison him good
idea do you have any really potent
poison
i have
one vial left
this is the rarest one and we've been
saving it but if
we need to get in there let's use it
it's it's a purple worm poison i pull
out my frost sword all right so she
takes out the vial and takes out this
special black cloth she uses to apply
poison to blades and she puts it
on the blade and
is there enough to put
on my bolts some on my bolts i believe
each poison vial does three coats three
coats okay a blade and two bolts two
bolts okay so well this is happening i'm
gonna channel my elven ancestry and
apply my the knowledge that i gleaned
when i was a young kid of hiding in the
wild and i'm going to use my mask of the
wild i'm gonna blend in with all these
rocks and stalactites and stalactites
and natural growth crystals
and just
disappear all right nico disappears and
turns into a with crystals and rocks
[Laughter]
so i've rubbed my hands together i know
this is a cool spell that i learned from
my buddy warren i've never used it
before
and then i touch you
and you become
all right you're invisible this is a
cool spell that i just learned
are you ready yeah
fly bob
i can't tell if he's flying oh he's
flying all right
go dude i hit my head on the
thing right there's a cool plan to
potentially
take out this creature
but there's a lot of things that can go
wrong i am ready to stab something right
now i'm hidden
and i'm going to move up silently up to
these crystals here give me just give me
roll and then creatures in the areas
trying to perceive you 14.
how far can i fly fly wherever you want
i can only make you fly for 10 minutes
but you can fly wherever you want until
then can i jump up and fly away yes cool
i do that i fly wait wait i say wait
okay
i almost made it to the door we need to
have a signal for you to attack so that
when we're ready like we can have it
ready
oh wait here i have something i have
this item called the horn
of silent alarm i will give this to you
and when you blow it any creature within
600 feet who has not deafened will hear
this whereas no one else can hear it and
you can use it
guys if you don't get out of your case
right now and deal with this we're going
to lose this guy so you got to move
next time on son of a dungeon hold on
jesus christ the astral plane starts
unfolding in his hands sword slice his
body in half and as you run past it
explodes and the chaos just starts
unfolding
worms bane williamsbane dragon slayer
we're gonna need your help absolutely
and i'm going to need yours we have some
of the world's finest adventurers
meeting finally luke we have one little
thing here i brought a donkey we gotta
go get this donkey
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh season two episode one part two
[Music]
all right everyone have their lines
mm-hmm all right
we got the script we took a live script
there yeah figured out all the things we
have to say yep and the order actually
had to remember them it's really hard
memorizing all the lines for the show it
really is you have to write the mistakes
into the script so it sounds natural
yeah
all right
cool so
oh yeah do you want to do uh oh yeah
this is the end of episode one all right
that's the end of the first episode the
end thanks for watching
don't worry about it
yeah we don't need i don't need to say
that
it's way better when it cuts